Every year, Japan marks Coming of Age Day,...
...a national holiday celebrating the entry into adulthood for teenagers turning 20.
But that legal age of adulthood is now dropping to 18.
The first such change in a century and a half.
With an aging population and a declining birth rate,...
...the thinking is it's time to get those teenagers contributing as adults...
...to the economy sooner.
The aging society causes a lot of social problems...
...such as pensions, economic growth and so forth,...
...but we are expecting the younger generation be more active.
But there are fears many young men and women with little financial knowledge...
...could fall into debt or even fall victim to fraud.
While the legal age for drinking, smoking and public gambling will remain at 20.
Other areas that have until now needed parental approval will be dropped to 18.
Such as applying for a credit card or mobile phone contract, renting an apartment,...
...applying for a bank loan or buying stocks.